pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en quelques secondes le plus violent
séisme de ces deux derniers siècles à
rayer agadir de la carte en le jour
s'est levé sur la cité ce qui avait été
une des villes les plus riantes du maroc
grandi sur une des plus belle rade du
monde n'était plus que ruines
[Musique]
voici ce qui reste de l'hôtel saada le
palace le plus moderne de cette cité qui
attirés par la douceur de son climat
les touristes du monde entier
[Musique]
e
l'anéantissement est à peu près totale
de la vieille ville de la ville nouvelle
résultat de tant d'efforts qui avait
donné à agadir son style moderne
il ne reste que des immeubles éventrés
et des tas de gravats
[Musique]
les 15 cents marins de la base
aéronavale française qui a été
miraculeusement épargnée avait été mis
aussitôt à la disposition des autorités
locales avec l'armée royale marocaine
ils avaient pu dès les premières heures
organiser les secours bientôt rejoint
par les éléments des bases américaines
première manifestation de la solidarité
qu'ils allaient se généraliser sous les
décombres il restait l'espoir de dégager
des blessés faible espoir
les sauveteurs les trouveraient ils
vivent c'est la question que chacun se
posait mais pour un rescapé
que d'espoirs déçus
[Musique]
cette ville de 40000 habitants a eu le
suprême malheur d'avoir été frappé
pendant son sommeil et les bilans les
plus pessimistes de la première heure
devait être dépassé 1000 2000 bientôt
4000 victimes et dans la chaleur de
sourde menace allait s'opposer aux
efforts et aux bonnes volontés
avec le manque d'eau l'apparition des
rares et les risques d'épidémies
[Musique]
un instant on donnait sans désemparer
les premiers soins aux blessés et parmi
eux des enfants
sur chacun de ces visages tout le
tragique destin d'agadir miraculeusement
sauvés il ne savait pas s'il avait
encore un père et une mère
[Musique]
colombes à l'heure de la coupe de france
60000 spectateurs du soleil à gogo comme
en plein mois de mai reims et nîmes sur
le terrain pour un peu on pourrait
croire qu'on assiste à la finale de la
coupe de france
petit ballet depuis anthony numéro 10 un
terreau gauche du stade de reims qui
jouent en culotte blanche ou prou kurras
à la limite de la surface de réparation
tiré par müller la balle revient dans
les pieds de müller burkina dit que très
imparfaitement la supériorité de race
durant la première mi temps un stade de
reims pétillant comme du champagne en
deuxième mi-temps le champagne c'est un
peu éventé et voici ce qui bat l'avant
centre nîmois qui inquiète très
sérieusement la défense rémoise
et puis c'est raïs l'ailier gauche qui
égalise
[Applaudissements]
tout est remise en question
bonne passe de pyatt n'y a qu'au pas
complètement démarqué qui centre en
retrait sur vincent 2 1 pour 1
le petit ballet du stade de reims on
commence sous l'impulsion de copains à
toi à moi un dribble une feinte un petit
régal pour les puristes finalement reims
gagnera par 3 à 2 voici d'ailleurs le
troisième but rémois que marc fontaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
agadir est désormais une ville morte
l'ordre d'évacuation en a chassé les
derniers survivants qui n'avait pas
encore fui ces ruines
[Musique]
et quelle ruine depuis la casbah
jusqu'au port où le séisme a laissé sa
marque au milieu des débris des grues et
des installations les quais
[Musique]
on a renoncé à donner aux morts une
sépulture particulière en raison de leur
nombre
il a fallu employer les bulldozer pour
secondes et les équipes de fossoyeurs et
creuser une immense fosse commune
[Musique]
dans les premières heures le roi du
maroc était venu rendre visite aux
rescapés auquel on avait ouvert un camp
de toile ils sont des milliers avec ce
qu'ont pris en charge les marins
français dans les hangars transformés en
un vaste centre d'hébergement
[Musique]
mais l'élan de solidarité n'a cessé de
se développer et avec les appareils qui
se sont succédé sur le terrain de
casablanca c'est un peu le monde entier
qui est venu à leur secours
quant à la ville interdite il ne restait
plus sous les ordres du prince moulay
hassan que des équipes dont la tâche
était désormais de mettre tout en oeuvre
pour couper le chemin à l'épidémie
[Musique]
sur les décombres qui recouvrent plus de
6000 morts peut-être allait s'abattre
détonne d'antiseptiques
[Musique]
elle devait faire appel aux avions pour
pulvériser des nuages de ddt
[Musique]
et pour des jours peut-être des semaines
il n'y aura plus rien de vivant dans
agadir en ruines
en dehors de quelques babes errante
[Musique]
en se rendant en algérie dans les
régions les plus reculées
le président de la république a voulu
préciser à l'armée qui se bat le sens de
sa mission
il a demandé aux soldats de poursuivre
plus que jamais la pacification sans
laquelle toute solution de la question
algérienne reste problématique
l'accueil de la population musulmane a
été dans tous les secteurs que le
général a visité un sincère témoignage
de confiance
en russie et en hiver tout le touriste
en taule air de ressemblance
cette fois la toque de fourrure
réglementaire coiffer le président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur chaban
delmas et les membres de la délégation
parlementaire française ils achevaient
leur voyage d'étude en urss par la
visite à zagour sq non loin de moscou
d'un célèbre monastère voué à la
formation des ports
[Musique]
et
un voyage qui n'aura négliger aucun des
aspects même les plus surprenants de la
vie soviétique
[Musique]
à londres on a beaucoup remarqué
l'arrivée de la reine mère elizabeth à
l'opéra il est vrai qu'elle était
accompagné de la princesse margaret et
de monsieur jones pour lequel les foules
se passionne depuis quelques temps
cette première sortie officielle des
fiancés a d'ailleurs valu à entonner une
première critique des membres de la
haute société
scandalisé ont pu porter dans sa
position un oeil et blanc et une
pochette sur un happy
mais monsieur jones a bon caractère il a
promis de s'initier très sérieusement
aux petites subtilités de l'étiquette
moyennant quoi tous les coeurs
britanniques pourront battre normalement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'aquarium d'anvers bien connue des
idéologues européen vient d'enrichir ses
collections d'un apport étonnant duo
docteur cathala créateur de l'aquarium
de nouméa
il s'agit de coraux vivants créature
mystérieuse qui tiennent dans la foi de
l'animal du végétal et du minéral
sous l'effet de la lumière noire ils
deviennent fluorescentes et offre aux
yeux un éblouissement de couleur rester
jusqu alors invisible
[Musique]
ces curieuses petite chorale sont tout
simplement les bouches par lesquels se
nourrissent les polypes l'aquarium de
nouméa 12 ont été apportées recèle
d'ailleurs d'autres étrangeté et
certains spécimens inconnu rascasse
acquis leurs coloris assure un
camouflage excellent dans les fonds de
coraux
[Musique]
rascasse poule qui gobent pour ainsi
dire sa proie toutes vivantes
poisson coffre ou poisson vaches dans
les corps ne sont rarement offensive car
c'est une bête plutôt débonnaire sèche
aux allures de caïman dont la peau est
pourvu de pigments qui en se rétractant
la fonte instantanément changer de
couleur nous dit branche limaces de mer
que leur couleur et leur système de
propulsion rend doublement curieuse
poisson grosses lèvres en fouilleurs de
sable et roches mères impénitent chinois
il en a l'air
poisson bannière l'un des autres les
plus élégants des mers coralliennes l'un
des plus gourmands hausse infrabec
l'aquarium de nouméa est aussi le seul
au monde à présenter cette espèce de
fossiles vivants
le nautile dont les pareil existait déjà
voici trois cent millions d'années
extraordinaire survivants du début de
l'époque primaire qui a résisté à tous
les bouleversements géologiques et aux
époques glacière un très vieux monsieur
c'est ainsi que venue de tahiti les
coraux fluorescents de l'aquarium
d'anvers nous ont entraînés jusqu'à
l'aquarium de nouméa sans apaiser notre
curiosité
il faudra un jour y aller voir
[Musique]